At Conor's Clinic, we understand your needs as a cancer patient.
Not only do we provide alternative solutions to cancer, we give hope when all seems lost.
We believe there are four major pillars in healing cancer.
One.
Cause.
What is the cause?
And how are we going to get rid of it?
Two.
Nutrition.
We discover your unique alternative approach.
Three.
Technology.
We use advanced rife therapy in healing.
Four.
Diet and detoxification.
We don't believe in standard protocols.
You need a personal diet with guidance and detox assistance.
Schedule a personal phone case review with Dr. Conor's.
We are committed to help those with cancer.
Let us take care of you.
Visit our website at conor's clinic.com or call us to schedule a case review.
Also, download a free copy of Dr. Conor's book, Stop Fighting Cancer and Start Treating
the Cause.